السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته. عليكم
السلام ورحمه الله وبركاته.
الله اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد
لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول
الله اشهد ان
محمدا رسول
الله حي على
الصلاه حي على
صلاه حي على الفلاح
حي على
الفلاح الله اكبر الله
اكبر لا اله الا
الله ان الحمد لله نحمده ونستعينه
ونستهديه ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا ومن
سيئات
اعمالنا من يهدي الله فهو المهتد ومن يضلل
فلن تجد له وليا مرشدا واشهد ان لا اله
الا الله وحده لا شريك له واشهد ان محمدا
عبده
ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على سيدنا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه والتابعين اما بعد
معاشر الموحدين عباد الله فان اصدق الكلام
كلام الله عز وجل وخير الهدي هدي محمد صلى
الله عليه وسلم وان شر الامور محدثاتها
وان كل محدثه بدعه وان كل بدعه ضلاله وان
كل ضلاله في النار اسال الله العظيم رب
العرش العظيم
بمنه وكرمه وعفوه ان يجيرني واياكم منها
انه ولي ذلك والقادر عليه اما بعد فيقول
الله سبحانه
وتعالى يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله حق
تقاته ولا تموتن الا وانتم مسلمون ويقول
سبحانه وتعالى يا ايها الناس اتقوا ربكم
الذي خلقكم من نفس واحده وخلق منها
زوجها وبث منهما رجالا كثيرا
ونساء واتقوا الله الذي تساءلون به
والارحام ان الله كان عليكم رقيبا ويقول
سبحانه وتعالى يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا
الله وقولوا قولا
سديدا يصلح لكم اعمالكم ويغفر لكم
ذنوبكم ومن يطع الله ورسوله فقد فاز فوزا
عظيما. اما
بعد اقام الاسلام علاقه المسلمين على
التواصل والمحبه
والتناصح في الله ولله وقوام
المجتمعات يقوم على التعارف والتعاون بين
الناس فمتى ما حكمت
العلاقات البغضاء واستشاحن فان هذا ينذر
بخراب المجتمع المجتمعات وضياع الدين
ولذلك كان من هديه صلى الله عليه وسلم انه
قال والذي نفسي بيده لا تدخلوا الجنه حتى
تسلموا والذي نفسي بيده لا تدخلوا الجنه
حتى تسلموا ولا تسلموا حتى تحابوا وافشوا
السلام تحابوا واياكم والبغضه فانها هي
الحالقه ويكمل صلى الله عليه وسلم يقول لا
اقول لكم تحلق الشعر ولكن تحلق الدين
والبغضه هي من الفعل بغض يبغض بغضا اي مقت
الشيء
وكرهه والمعروف
بالكراهيه اسلام
estب
مسلم الله سبحانه وتعالى
[Silence]
‏understand
people this is nations
‏by
andliad
theuction
ofent
and حديث ابو رضي الله عنه صلى الله عليه
[Silence]
‏parad صلى الله عليه
وسلم جنه
‏Musl until
another life here is not enter until you
become a not be complete
and you
حديث will not
صلى الله عليه
[Silence]
وسلم صلى الله عليه
صلى الله عليه
وسلم
احاديث صلى الله عليه
حديث صلى الله عليه
‏I
not الحالقه التي تحقق الشاق انما الحالقه
التي تحلق
الدين لم نسمع من السنه النبويه ولا
الاثار الثابته عنه صلى الله عليه وسلم
كلمه اكثر ردعا ونهيا من كلمته صلى الله
عليه وسلم حين قال فانها الحالقه لا اقول
لكم تحلق الشعر ولكن تحلق الدين علمنا
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم اسباب التالف
واستجلاب الموده فيما بيننا كما حذرنا مما
يورث
التنافر
والتشاحن علمنا صلى الله عليه وسلم ان لا
يكتمل اسلام المرء لا يكتمل اسلام المرء
ولا ايمانه حتى يحب بعضنا بعضا ثم وجه
النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم امته الى اعظم سبب للتحاب فقال
وافشوا السلام بينكم اعظم واسهل
سبب اعظم واسهل وسيله اعظم واسهل طريقه
قال وافشوا السلامه حابوا اي افشوه بينكم
والمراد نشره والاكفار منه فالله عز وجل
جعل افشاء السلام سببا للمحبه وجعل المحبه
سببا لكمال الاسلام
والايمان ثم قال صلى الله عليه وسلم
واياكم والبغضه وهي الكره والعداوه فانها
هي
الحالقه هي الحالقه اي هي الخصله التي
شانها ان تهلك وتستاصل الدين كما يستاصل
الموسى
الشعر
حديث صلى الله عليه
وسلم حديث صلى الله عليه
[Silence]
‏another prop صلى الله عليه
وسلم
usut and
‏usn things
couldro you
could عليه
‏dire صلى الله عليه وسلمجلام
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه
وسلم
جنه وفي الحديث الاخر عنه صلى الله عليه
وسلم قال الا اخبركم بافضل من بافضل من
درجه الصيام والصلاه والصدقه قالوا بلى
قال صلاح ذات البين فان فساد ذات البين هي
الحالقه حديث صلى الله عليه
[Silence]
‏more
حسي صلى الله عليه
‏more propet
said putting things right between
peopleing
people another
simple
to put
[Silence]
اصلاح ذات البين
اي السعي في اصلاح العلاقات بين الناس
ورفع ما بينهم من خصومات ودفعهم الى
الالفه والمحبه وهو الامر الافضل في
المنفعه بين الناس واقامه
المجتمعات لان اصلاح ذات البين ليس فيه
منفعه شخصيه اصلاح ذات البين المنفعه فيه
ظاهره ومباشره
للجميع وانعكاساتها الايجابيه تعم
المجتمع ثم قال صلى الله عليه وسلم وفساد
ذات البين اي فساد ذات البين وترك الساعي
في الاصلاح يؤدي الى الحالقه اي القاطعه
والمنهيه التي تاتي على كل شيء وتحلقه
وتقطعه من جذوره سواء من امور الدنيا
والدين
حديث صلى الله عليه
وسلم
understand
الله صلاه صيام
صدقه wondering how you wondering right
‏that
could
people resolving disputes between people
closing the gaps close the gaps between
themarifying the issues bring them
closer to each other in hope to fix a
relationship that is greater in the eye
of all your could
be so
‏things that are could easily on a daily
basis not paying attention to if you
know relationship is ruined between two
brothers try to collect them together
trying to bridge the gaps clarify the
the misunderstanding the
miscommunication give them a chance to
fix the
relationship and that's a position and
your status will be elevated
insall and again we said this is not a
‏comm
nothing and clear among
people and is also nothing
wor a bad
conflictcommunication of
understandingpute
بارك الله لي ولكم بالقران في القران
العظيم ونفعني واياكم بهدي بهدي سيد
المرسلين اقول ما تسمعون واستغفر الله لي
ولكم فاستغفروه انه الغفور الرحيم
[Silence]
الحمد لله رب العالمين والصلاه والسلام
على المبعوث رحمه
للعالمين اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على سيدنا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين اللهم وارضى
عنا وعنهم اجمعين
ويتاكد امر الائتلاف والتراحم والعفو
عندما تتشابك العلاقات بمصاهره ونسب ونحو
ذلك حيث انها من ايه ايه من ايات الله
سبحانه وتعالى في قوله وهو الذي خلق من
الماء بشرا فجعله نسبا وصهرا وكان ربك
قديرا ففي هديه صلى الله عليه وسلم الحث
والترغيب على اصلاح العلاقات بين الناس
وفيه بيان ان الفساد عظيم وفيه بيان ان
افساد العلاقات بين الناس تهدم الدنيا
والدين وفساد
عظيم روى ابو ايوب
الانصاري عن عن رضي الله عنه عن النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم
قال لا يحل لمسلم ان يهجر اخاه فوق
ثلاث لا يحل
المساله فيها حل وحرمه لا يحل
لمسلم لامرئ مسلم ان يهجر اخاه فوق ثلاث
يلتقيان فيصد هذا ويصد هذا وخيرهما الذي
يبدا
بالسلام وينبغي ايها
المسلم ينبغي عليك ان يكون لك دور في
الاصلاح وااره ما وازاله ما شجر من خلافات
ونزاعات بسبب بنزغات الشيطان واغواء النفس
الاماره قال سبحانه وتعالى انما المؤمنون
اخوه فاصلحوا بين اخويكم واتقوا الله
لعلكم ترحمون ابو ايوب الانصاري رضي الله
عنه صلى الله عليه
وسلم more
[Silence]
‏acc صلى الله عليه
سلامates
first and now finally
wouldম a role in
sit you are part of it you are part
‏according to the سبحانه وتالى says the
believers are
but so make your brothers
and that you may receive his mercy اللهم
صل وسلم على سيدنا محمد في الاولين وصل
وسلم على سيدنا محمد في الاخرين وصل وسلم
على سيدنا محمد في كل وقت
وحين اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على سيدنا محمد
حتى ترث الارض ومن عليها وانت خير
الوارثين اللهم ارحم ضعفنا اللهم ارحم
ضعفنا واجمع شملنا واجبر كسرنا ويسر امرنا
و وفرج همنا واشرح
صدورنا ووسع ارزاقنا واقضي عنا ديننا
اللهم تقبل توبتنا واغسل حوبتنا واجب
دعوتنا وثبت حجتنا واهدي قلوبنا وسدد
السنتنا واسلل سخيمه قلوبنا يا رب
العالمين اللهم اشف مرضانا ومرضى المسلمين
وارحم موتانا وموتى المسلمين وعافي
مبتلانا واجعل لنا بكل دعوه اجابه وبلغنا
رضاك يا ارحم الراحمين اللهم اعز الاسلام
والمسلمين اللهم اعز الاسلام والمسلمين
واعلي رايتي الحق والدين المبين اللهم
اصلح احوالنا واحوال المسلمين في في كل
مكان اللهم اصلح احوالنا واحوال المسلمين
في كل مكان اللهم الطف باهل غزه وسائر ارض
فلسطين المحتله اللهم ارفع الكرب عنهم
اللهم ارفع الكرب عنهم وامن خوفهم اللهم
امن خوفهم وكن لهم معينا ومؤيدا ونصيرا
اللهم اجبر كسرهم وارحم شهيدهم وشاف
جريحهم واجعل لهم فرجا ومخرجا برحمتك يا
ارحم الراحمين اللهم عليك بعدوك وعدوهم
فانهم لا يعجزونك يا لطيف يا لطيف يا لطيف
الطف بهم ويسر لهم واكتب لهم فرجا قريبا
يا ارحم الراحمين اللهم اجعل هذا المجتمع
سخاء رخاء وسائر بلاد المسلمين اللهم
تجاوز عنا السيئات وتحمل عنا
التبعات اللهم اجزي والدينا عنا خير
الجزاء اللهم متعهم باعمارهم
وابصارهم وقواتهم واسماعهم ابدا ما
ابقيتهم يا رب العالمين اللهم بارك لهم في
عملهم وعمرهم واختم لنا ولهم بخاتمه
الاحسان اللهم من كان منهم ميتا فارحمهم
وصب على قبرهم شهابيب الرحمات يا رب
العالمين اللهم صل على سيدنا محمد وعلى
اله وصحبه وسلم اللهم اجزي سيدنا محمد صلى
الله عليه وسلم خير ما عنا خير ما جزيت
نبيا عن امته اللهم احينا على سنته وامتنا
على ملته واوردنا حوضه واكتب لنا شفاعته
يا رب العالمين عباد الله ان الله يامر
بالعدل والاحسان وايتاء ذي القربى وينهى
عن الفحشاء والمنكر والبغي
يعظكم لعلكم
تذكرون واخر دعوانا ان الحمد لله رب
العالمين الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان لا
اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول الله حي على
الصلاه حي على الفلاح قد قامت الصلاه قد
قامت الصلاه الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله
الا
الله استقيمواد استووا سووا الصب سدوا
الخلل الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين سبح اسم ربك الاعلى الذي خلق فسوى
والذي قدر فهدى والذي اخرج
المرعى فجعله
غثاء احوى سنقرئك فلا
تنسى الا ما شاء
الله انه يعلم الجهر وما
يخفى ونيسرك لليسرى فذكر ان نفعت
الذكرى سيذكر من يخشى
ويتجنبها الاشقى الذي يصلى النار
الكبرى
ثم لا يموت فيها ولا
يحيا قد افلح من تزكى وذكر اسم ربه
فصلى بل تؤثرون الحياه الدنيا والاخره خير
وابقى ان هذا لفي الصحف
الاولى صحف ابراهيم
وموسى
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
الله الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين بسم
الله والضحى والليل اذا سجى ما ودعك ربك
وما قلى ولا الاخره خير لك من
الاولى ولسوف يعطيك ربك
فترضى الم يجدك
يتيما فاوى
ووجدك
عائلا ووجدك يتيما
فاوى ووجدك
عائلا
فاغنى ووجدك
ضالا
فهدى ووجدك
عائلا
فاغناه فاما اما اليتيم فلا تقهر واما
السائل فلا
تنهر
واما بنعمه ربك فحدث
الله
سمع
الله لمن حمده
الله اكبر
الله
আল্লাহু আকবার আল্লাহু আকবার
আল্লাহু আকবার
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله সলামু আলাইকুম just
মিং ইনশল্লাহ first অল
আলহামদুলিল্লাহ হউটিফুল রামদান
হাফিফজ
তাকব
হাসান wasஹful
[Silence]
மரமஜிங் ‏in serving the so all of tasks
take lot of effort and lot ofination but
i really happy to see this
alহামদুলিল্লাহ we went through this
without any maor concerns or
is and everyone of you need a real you
know thanks from me and from the bo of
mcct now let me just come to the
real come some of the basic things that
we raised durh of ramadan
‏sister
wasable alles and have 30
4000esending
this we
alsoedana about 16000 plus and 15000
[Silence]
আহামদুলিল্লাহ strong 75
en we need to
make the funding ‏it some funds during
the
mon0000
colct but there some money that is free
of cost to you which is again we
keepinding this is aona state tax and
that redirection could be very signicant
it could be in access of you
know000 andஷ get all of that is back
there with a f in hand pleas take a you
don't know
‏mentate what your taculations are just
whatever that portion is it doesn't have
to be 2000 plus number is smaller num so
we are very wing to see how much
participation we can get so it can make
our prram
healthy and we have about 11 more days
for the for the last
204 have 11 more days tobute that to get
the reward the back so pleas make
sure but that's want to make sure that
that is you know everyone of you is a
understand it b they have a chance to at
least make an effort to make that
payment towards school rather than
giving the money to the state of
Arizona now just in conclusion we
and
after pleas donate gener other
bo have exibition that is here and there
is a part of that donation is going to
the masjid also so if you are able
‏take a மமெ இ
theஜிம்னசியம் pleaseஸ் by என்ஜய் தேங்கயூ